ladies and gentlemen please welcome your  host with the most Roger Goodell mix 70  welcome to my greetings everybody and  remember even if you win tonight no  celebrating cricket you're fine now for  our first award best kicker who doesn't  give AF the winner is more kick King  don't gamble it away in Vegas yes I'm  kidding ooh what's that I said boom men  without Facebook moving on the award for  best perfect dose do did not see this  coming by Dan perfect I got robbed and  now and in memoriam to honor everyone  who sees him with a complete lie like  it's some sad stuff now it's time for  the biggest award of the evening  the best team in gridiron ice and the  nominees are the Patriot and the Falcon  unless you play the Super Bowl but I'm  the best quarterback of all time  according to me Rodgers out Rodgers out  of the playoffs